so
let me let me ask you about this because
this is something that i feel
like pretty strongly about like
over the years like all 21 of them
like you've kind of like been uh
like sort of a whipping boy you know
it's yeah it's like
everyone just be mean to danger aaron
like where what makes jackass so special
is this like camaraderie this charisma
or could not charisma this chemistry
that we have between
us yet like
it's just like bullying you've been yeah
you've been the victim of very much
bullying for sure for like you know a
lot of the time
dude and and it's hard for me sometimes
because
well a lot of times for any purpose of
somebody being
bullied but i'm you know in a sense
being uh outcasted and bullied
and it's all in good fun is so everyone
says but the reality is is no matter
what eventually you just get
tired of the same repetitive jokes that
are being
put towards you right and
that's it's different because it's my
job i'm not like this
in person like if you [ __ ] with me like
i'm sorry you
like i'm not gonna just take it like i
do with while we're filming
stuff because right it's we need that
person like
as a group we really do like if we
didn't have me
i guess
what happens in this situation a lot of
times is like
one person will say something and in
order for them not to get picked
on they make sure that they're dishing
out
and then all of a sudden everyone else
will just kind of follow suit right
behind it's a normal thing in life
people do it right same way in order for
them not to feel like oh they're coming
after me
let's go after that person and then my
the attention will not be on me
anymore or you know what i'm saying and
yeah it's almost like maybe maybe
they're getting bullied at home but
they're not kids
all i know uh is who i am
you know as as you getting hot
yeah getting a little hot can we open up
that window sorry dude you can max air
that stuff and a little blaster fan
mm-hmm this thing's set up for all
terrain
do you does it ever come also like
all-terrain interviews because people
people who watch jackass they feel so
close to you guys they feel like they're
your buddies
so do people come up to you and feel
like they can bully you because no
no i think most people come up to me and
they're they can relate to
what happened tonight that's cool
because no matter like
yeah there's like you know there's the
cool guy and the cool guy like everyone
thinks that's cool that cool guy's
getting picked on
all the time too like even if it's just
people don't
respect that person or something like we
we're all human beings
like we have like we need to take care
of each other
what does morrissey say like i'm just a
human and
and i i need to be loved yeah
there you go i can't remember what we
were just talking about though you said
that um
i said everybody bullies you yeah and i
mean a lot of times it's funny i mean
like yeah i mean a lot of it's funny and
i do agree with you that maybe like to
an extent we need that
but i said when i brought this up
initially i feel strongly about it
because i think that
you know for a lot of the time it's just
gone too far it's
it's gone past the point of being like
playful and fun and it's like
what's the point it gets to the point
where it's like what's the point
of saying mean things to a person when
uh there's not even cameras being rolled
and a lot of times like not a lot of
times but sometimes and it's not just to
me it's to everybody like
we latch on to somebody else to
take the blame off of us and that's what
happens with this we got nine guys ten
guys together whatever
now it's like a morning everybody gets
[ __ ] there's no question about that but
it just goes
with you it's just it's been too much a
lot of the time and it's been when
cameras aren't rolling and it's like
yeah
and and i've just you know i i i'm
speaking up for you man because i i
love you and you're a great guy hey you
don't deserve that [ __ ]
thank you yeah thank you well here's
what here's what you just said is i'm a
great guy
i mean i don't know if i'm a great guy
but i'm a good person i'm a good guy
and at the end of the day and at the end
of the day
whatever people say or do to me like i
go home i'm like dude i'm killing it in
life
like i'm killing it in life i've got the
best life
i'm the same person i was before i
started
jackass like i'm i'm i feel like you
can't say
[ __ ] to me like literally you can't say
[ __ ] to me that's gonna like make me not
really know who i am and respect
i myself i have to be really strong to
be able to still continue to hear that
[ __ ] over and over again because
i'm not letting it it does affect me and
eventually
i get over it and i'm just like fine
then you guys can
talk [ __ ] to yourself i'm going to walk
over here go back to one of your nine
houses go back to one of my nine houses
and chill dog
but you have to be strong like your
shirt says
you do in in life especially when people
are like giving
[ __ ] for no reason all you want to do is
crawl up into a ball and be like [ __ ]
they're right i
suck but you don't you know i don't suck
i don't care well just look at the
people
you know it's like even like the
comments on some of the videos it's like
dude
who's actually saying that and why would
you say that to anybody dude comments on
social media it's like the way that the
world works right now with social media
and how easy it is to just
ridicule people and make them feel like
[ __ ] for no reason it's ridiculous
that's turned into normal society now
and that's not how we need to live like
what's the point in telling everybody
what they're doing wrong
instead of like saying hey you're doing
this right and you could fix this
or do that better but you're not always
just doing wrong like
like that's not going to benefit us all
it's a spiritual
axiom meaning like an immutable law of
nature
that the way we treat others is a
reflection of how we feel about
ourselves
and that's why it's all the hating and
negativity you know it's like
you got some [ __ ] [ __ ] going on with
yourself and you don't like it and so
you take it out on other people
like in general like happy healthy
people don't [ __ ] on others
yeah you know well you but but it's
different with this because
we this is this is i mean honestly i am
i'm 100 sure that we all love each other
like yeah it's like like yeah i feel
like we're family
and you have a brother or sister and and
you love that person
and you still pick on that person and
it's not it doesn't excuse it but
usually
what happens when you get older in life
like in your 40s and 50s is you're like
mature enough to then say you know i'm
sorry i
i don't mean to pick i didn't mean to
pig on you young but we aren't
mature we are jackass like we aren't
supposed to grow up we're supposed to be
like doing this as i guess forever but
so
that normal like growing up phase and
and being like hey man
i just want to let you know i love you
and like i tell you i'm sorry
yeah i know i tell that to you too yeah
dude so do you think maybe the other
guys feel like
since you're you sort of said like you
know you you almost play this role of
being like that out of a joke
but it's almost their job also to like
throw it at you and kind of like give
you the [ __ ] like they're like
this should just work for me like yeah
maybe you might have a little bearing
and you know
it's like it's just it's accepted it's
it's
what as we've done for so long yeah but
you know i
i don't i i would like to think that if
i were on the other side of it
like i wouldn't be like rousting
a dude hard over and over again and
because i can see when i do it
to some of our new crew or whatever i
can see their
their emotions and their their whole
like outlook on like their spirit like
like when i when when i see other people
start doing things to them
i see them instantly just like go into
this like oh man
i i i'm like oh no like and it totally
makes it hard enough coming in like to a
new crew and then you get
rousted it's like jesus maybe i don't
belong here well there's
like but you should you should get
[ __ ] with
you know but there's a certain a point
at which
because i get [ __ ] with i know like
okay
it's about to cross the line i don't
want to like there's no point in me
hurting his or her feelings for anything
right now
we're not even filming what's the point
hey man just know this i'm just trying
to teach you something that's it that's
all
cool and then it's like oh okay cool and
then it's like seniors and freshmen
yeah it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude